- And we're live.
Welcome everybody to
another YouTube hangout.
Excited to be back with an old friend.
He's been on before.
Crushed it.
You guys loved him, Peter
Voogd, he is the bestselling
author, talking about how to
make six figures in six months,
that was the topic of our
last hangout about a year ago.
And today we're going to talk
about an important problem
that a lot of entrepreneurs
face, about how to master
the art of productivity.
I'm wearing his shirt
because I loved it so much
last time, he shipped me one.
So, Become Legendary.
Peter, welcome back, man.
- Thank you.
The shirt looks amazing.
I compliment it.
It fits well, so I'm glad
you like it, and we're all
trying to become legendary, so
thanks for the support, man.
- I love it.
So for people who aren't
familiar, it's maybe their first
exposure to you, just
give a quick intro on who
Peter Voogd is all about.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm honestly
someone that's really
dedicated to serving and
helping entrepreneurs.
I started my first business when I was 15,
doing eBay, and was able
to build a team that way
and take advantage of buying
and selling and the internet
and leveraged technology, and
once I saw a piece of that,
Evan, at a young age, and
saw that I could make money
on my terms, I really didn't
want to get a normal job.
I tried it.
I couldn't stand it, and I never got
a normal job after that.
Was able to get into sales
and got into a international
wholesale company, was able
to work my way up there.
I was able to train almost
6,000 sales rep and to be
a manager, and I wanted to
build my own organization,
and that's where the failure
came in, where I thought
because I had succeeded, it
was easy to motivate others.
Succeeding yourself and
then motivating others
is two different ballgames.
So I had to go through a lot of failure
because I wasn't a good leader.
I was trying to develop
myself, so I went dead broke.
All my savings went out the window.
I didn't have enough money to
go through the drive-through,
and I had to build from scratch.
So when I was 21, 22, I
was literally frustrated,
discouraged, and overwhelmed,
and I finally turned my mindset
around, and I got a mentor.
I invested in myself, and through
a framework, that I talked
on the other video, I was able to get
to that six-figure mark.
And I left the six-figure job making close
to three hundred grand as a
22-year-old, very comfortable.
I had the team delegated.
I had a lot of free time,
but my mission was growing.
So then I started Game Changers Academy.
I started Game Changers
Incorporated, and I had my books
come out, and everything
I've done since has just been
focused on helping entrepreneurs thrive,
because I see so much BS out there.
I wanted to give people
a very proven, tactical,
real-world blueprint on
how to be successful.
So now I've done six figures in six months
in seven different industries.
I've been able to travel
the world speaking.
I was just in Dubai speaking,
so I just love what I do, man.
But I've literally
failed my way to success.
I want people to know that.
I've had a lot of failures as well.
- There's that patented
Peter Voogd energy.
I love it, man.
- Ah, I'm always fired up.
Let's go!
- Let's talk about the
subject, productivity.
I mean, entrepreneurs,
we're doing everything.
We're the CEO to the janitor, you know,
there's no free time.
What are your thoughts?
What are your suggestions?
How do we master the art?
- Yeah, so, here's the deal.
I was the worst at time
management and productivity
at the beginning, which is
why I am good at it now,
because I was so bad.
I would work 40, 50 hours a week
and I wasn't getting the results I wanted.
I felt like I was always
busy and people say,
well, if you're not getting
the results, work more.
So I worked up to 80 hours a week,
and still was not getting results.
So I had to figure out why
I wasn't getting results.
So I read every time
management book I could.
I hired a time management,
someone just for helping
me with time management,
and slowly but surely,
I was able to figure out a
system and a proven program
that I coined in the last couple years
on how to help me be more productive.
And I felt like I was
working all the time.
I felt like my business was running me.
I felt like my to-do
list was always growing.
I was overwhelmed with information,
and I felt like no
matter what I was doing,
I was just maintaining my business.
So I think the importance of
productivity is astronomical,
and I think people need to
understand that they have
to be disciplined and strategic
instead of working all the time.
So you have to ask
yourselves these questions
that I asked myself, and then
we can dive into the tactics.
And I'd love to hear you, as
well, kind of vibe in with me,
because you're amazing at productivity.
You getting a lot of big things done,
but you also have an
exceptional lifestyle, too.
So how can we improve
productivity when we're
already working at max capacity?
That was my problem.
I wanted to improve my
productivity and time management,
but I was maxed out.
So I was thinking how
can I improve when I have
no free time, but that's the reason why
I needed to focus on time management.
How can we take more time off
to get energy and creativity
when we have so much to do, right?
How do we deal with
all these distractions?
How do we systemize
productivity and create result
rituals to help with the
most important goals?
And how do you figure
out your highest value,
highest leverage activities?
And these are the questions I asked.
So I created a framework and a
blueprint that I've done.
We can dive into that, but
I think there's different
definitions of productivity.
I think if you talk to 10 entrepreneurs,
there's probably going to be 10
different definitions, right?
I think productivity's a couple things.
One, it's a productive
life that's focused on
and committed to producing and progressing
towards your ideal vision.
And I also think it's the
use of your time, energy,
intelligence and resources
in a manner calculated
to move you closer to meaningful goals.
And productivity isn't just
results in getting things done.
It's about creating free
time for your family,
doing what you want, and having
100% control over your future.
I don't think it's
about doing more faster,
it's about doing the
right things deliberately.
So the importance is amazing,
man, and I just wanted
to talk about it because
I get this all the time.
How do I be more productive?
I feel like I'm capped out.
And I see a lot of CEOs
and a lot of entrepreneurs
that are crushing it
in the business world,
but they don't know their kids.
And I don't think that's
a game changer at all.
Like if you don't know your
family and you're so busy
you can't do things you
love, because when you get
to the end of your life,
you're not going to look back
and wish you had more transactions.
You're going to wish
that you spent more time
with those you cared about,
built meaningful relationships,
and you maximized life's experiences.
So I'm fired up, man.
I'm ready.
We could dive in, or,
what are your thoughts on
how important productivity is?
- Yeah, I think you, I mean,
it's getting your work done.
You have a big goal, you have
a dream, you want to have
an impact, you got to
make sure that every day,
as much as possible,
you're grinding it out.
And yes, part of that is
having the family life
and everybody's idea of
balance's a little bit different,
but the key is not to have
regret, that you're not
looking back and saying, "I
wished I did that differently."
- Exactly, for sure.
And that's what I've tried
to do, because I felt like
I was missing every family
event, and the weird thing was,
here's what was triggering me to be able
to ask these questions.
I saw people with more
responsibility than me
getting more done and
getting better results,
and they had more free time.
So, I'm like, there's a problem here.
Something's going on if
they're getting way more done
and I have worse results
but I'm busy all the time.
So the first thing that I
had to do, is I had to really
figure out what was killing my momentum
and what was stopping my productivity.
What were the distractions
that were killing my momentum
and my getting in the zone time?
So the first question I'd ask is
what are your biggest
productivity killers?
What are the things that have killed
your productivity in the past?
Because if you don't become aware,
we have to start with
the ground level here.
If you don't become aware of
where you're wasting time,
that will always come
up, month after month,
year after year.
So it can be distractions
as far as social media.
I can be internet sometimes.
It can be sleeping in.
It can be people interrupting
you all the time, right?
It can be lack of planning.
Maybe it's your environment.
But I challenge people.
What are three to five
productivity killers
that have been hurting you in the last,
let's say, six months?
And I think when you do that,
I think multi-tasking's one.
I think notifications on the phone is one.
But I challenge people, what
three are costing you the most?
Like, for me, I had to put my phone away,
and whenever I was writing
or creating or producing,
I, a lot of times, I create
a technology-free zone, Evan,
where I don't have internet.
You ever have that where
you're working on something
and all of the sudden
you're on the internet?
And you're like, what am I watching
these cat videos for, right?
(laughs)
Or whatever people watch.
But I was getting so distracted,
so now I had to figure out
what two or three of these
are costing me the most?
Another big game changer for me was
I have zero notifications on my phone.
My phone's never on loud.
It's always on silent, because I answer
the phone on my terms.
I have no, like, a lot of
people get their dopamine
fix by, oh, pop, notification.
Oh, my gosh. That's amazing.
We have, Twitter just gave you a message.
Oh, my gosh.
You got a message on Snapchat.
You got an email.
And people are always
adapting and adjusting
versus taking full
control of their schedule.
So that's the first thing.
And then I would create a prevention plan
for each productivity killer, right?
So whatever is hurting your productivity,
put a prevention plan in place.
Because if you don't
have a plan to interrupt
your interruptions, your plans
will always be interrupted.
So that's the first key as well.
And do you want to just stop?
I have, like, four or five
keys that are simplified
that I can go through.
Whatever you feel like you want to do.
Do you want to have a
conversation about it
or me just dive in?
'Cause I could go all day.
- I want to do both.
Like the chat is blowing up.
We've got questions
coming out of everywhere,
but I want to hear the,
before we get into those,
let's do the five and then
we'll hit up the chat.
- Perfect.
Now, how many, we have six
hours today right, together?
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- I'm just kidding. But,
yeah, my energy's sky high.
I'm excited.
I have my coffee.
So the first thing, I'm
going to go through five
and then I'm going to deep dive.
Simplicity.
Once you simplify your
business and your life,
you have massive clarity
and endless motivation.
When you have fuzzy thinking,
it's so hard to take big action.
And complexity is the
enemy of real execution.
The more complex you make something,
the less likely you are
to take action, right?
That's number one.
Number two, strategically scheduling
everything in your schedule.
Your schedule is a reflection
of your integrity and priorities.
When I see people flying
by the cuff of their pants,
not strategically thinking
things through, I just think
their business is going
to eventually shut down,
because you can only do that so far.
You have to really be intentional.
Number three is seizing
and maximizing each day.
If you don't make the most of your days,
you'll never have
amazing weeks and months.
But if you make the most of your days,
the weeks and months take
care of themselves, right?
Fourth, staying intentional.
Those who are outcome-focused
and result-focused
and are intentional produce
results like nobody else.
And lastly, for me, this was the big one,
your success environment
and success orientation.
Most people are controlled
by everything external
and they're never fully in control
of exactly where they want to go.
But the achievers are always
focused on being in control
of their agenda and not
letting other people interrupt
their productivity, their
mindset, their standards
and where they're going.
So, that's the five, so
we can definitely dive in.
So, the first thing is absolute clarity.
We talked a little on the
last episode that we did
on absolute clarity, but I want
to dive a little bit deeper.
You have to learn how to master yourself
and know how to spark your own fire.
The more you have to count on
someone else to motivate you,
the less money you'll make and
the less effective you'll be.
So learn how to master yourself,
how to spark your own fire.
And how I did that was I put
my plan, I put my vision,
I put my values and my reasons
and my goals, on one page.
Whew, and I, literally, Evan, I have
this is from 2015, but I...
- There's the page.
- Yeah, but I have like
five or six of them
that I redo every couple months,
but it's like I've done this since 2012.
I had it in the shower, above the shower.
- It's laminated.
I love it.
But let me tell you what's on that page,
because it's such a game changer for me.
First is your ideal outcome.
A lot of people don't even
know their ideal outcome
of what they want to accomplish
in the next six months.
If I ask a hundred
entrepreneurs, hey, what is the
ideal outcome for you and your business?
How many hours are you working?
How much money are you bringing in?
What's your subscribers look like?
How involved are you
in the business, right?
How big is your team?
What exactly are your marketing tactics?
They're like, I have no idea.
99 out of a hundred don't know.
So what's your ideal outcome?
And don't base this off
your past or limitations.
Base this off what's possible
and your potential, right?
So just a simple paragraph.
What's your ideal outcome?
I don't really like to
say vision statement,
'cause that's over-talked
about and over-played,
but I like to tell people
it's your ideal outcome.
So once you have that on top, then,
this is big, your core values.
What are most important to
you in life and business?
Because you want to build a
business around your values,
not settle for a business that
doesn't match your values,
because then you're living
incongruently, right?
And people do this all the time.
But in the new economy,
in 2017, there's no reason
why you can't create and
design your ideal lifestyle
or be picky and choosy with your business
because you're becoming so valuable.
So values.
For me, it's family, freedom, autonomy,
and then legacy and
impact, even before income.
People always say, well what about income?
It's like, yeah, that's
very important to me,
but I have leverage where
I don't need income.
So what's cool for me
is, my values are intact
to where I can say yes
and no to any opportunity
that comes to me based on my values.
Like, I've turned down speeches, Evan,
for close to 10 grand.
One was in Chicago in January.
That's enough to turn
anything down in Chicago,
'cause it's freezing.
Sorry to all the Chicago people.
You probably agree.
But anyways, I turn down
speeches that are well-paid,
and I've done three
speeches in the inner city
in LA for underprivileged kids.
Now if my values were number one, money,
I'd probably turn down the free speeches
and do all the paid ones,
but my value's impact and giving back.
So you got to define what your values are.
After that, it's your top five goals.
So what are the big five
for the next six months?
And I'll kind of run
through this kind of quick,
but what are the five things that you want
to accomplish and get done
in the next six months?
And then underneath that, it's
your most powerful reasons.
What are the reasons that drive you?
What are your top five
most compelling reasons,
'cause this is the fuel that gets you
to take action on the top five.
So what are your five biggest reasons?
You might have to write down
like 20 or 30 and simplify
to get to the ones that mean something,
but if you don't have,
if you're not waking up
at four or five in the
morning fired up and excited,
your reasons aren't strong enough.
I'm serious.
So get some strong reasons of why
you want to do what you do.
And lastly, what's your one
key skill or one key habit
that's most relevant to
your six-month vision
that you're going to focus on for the next
month or two until it's mastered?
You see, one big part
of productivity, Evan,
is focusing on mastery versus overload.
There's so much information.
There's all this technology.
There's podcasts, YouTube,
audios, videos, books,
trainings, seminars, and
a lot of entrepreneurs
use it as a cop out,
to where they're like,
oh, I want to keep learning and growing,
and instead of executing
on what they already know,
they want to learn more, and say,
well, I'm still studying.
No, no, no.
You need to execute and
get addicted to outcomes,
not just information.
So now you measure
everything you're studying
against this one-page productivity plan,
and if you do that, it
gives you so much clarity.
Now the goal is to let
your vision guide you,
not your current circumstances, right?
So that's the first thing,
is just simplifying.
Do you have any questions
or do you want me to answer
any of the subscribers'
or fans' questions,
I'd be happy to.
- Yeah, let's do it.
First off, loved all the
value, man, it's great.
You're just firin' it at us.
I love it.
I'm trying to keep track
of all the comments.
It's nuts with all the
questions coming in.
- Give me the weirdest one.
I'm just kidding.
- The weirdest one?
Um. The weirdest one.
- Don't.
It's going to be way too weird.
- Okay, you know what?
Actually, people want to know exactly
what time we wake up.
- Oooh. Good question.
So, here's the, I used to be
obsessed with the exact time.
When you're in a successful
state of mind, I've been around,
I've been very fortunate to
be around a lot of seven,
eight, nine figure earners,
very, very successful people.
I was with Ryan Blair at
his house two days ago.
Do you know Ryan?
I think you did a...
- Yeah.
Yeah, and he sold a company
for 782 million dollars.
That, I can't conceptualize that,
selling a company and getting
that much, but I noticed,
and I noticed from a lot of people,
it's not about exactly when you wake up.
It's about what you do when you're awake
and how productive you are.
So for me it's different.
If I'm traveling and
speaking, I'll wake up
at different times, but
in my sacrifice stages,
like when I was in my early, early 20s,
I wouldn't get much sleep.
I'd get five, five-and-a-half, six hours,
because I'd be hustling
and grinding, sacrificing.
Now that I've built the foundation,
I like to get seven to eight hours.
You ask me five, six
years ago, I would say,
you don't need eight
hours, you're a hustler.
You need four hours.
Forget sleep.
That's just not smart,
'cause productivity,
you need to have the right sleep.
But it depends on what stage you're at.
And to be honest, figure
out when you're in the zone
and when you're most creative
and when you have the most willpower.
I know people, Evan, that
go to bed at two or three.
Like one of my friends
who's a recording artist,
he is the most productive
from eleven to three
in the morning, and then
he'll get up at ten or eleven.
I know some people who
conk out and go to bed
at nine or ten, and they're
productive from four to eight.
So it really, it's not about
exactly what time you wake up,
it's about when you're most
effective and productive,
and delegating all your
highest-value, most profit-producing
activities to that time.
So don't get on the subject of what time,
get on the subject of what you're doing
and is that your most productive hours?
Good question, though.
And that's changed.
That would've been a
different answer years ago.
- Yeah, and parenthood
changes that, too, as well.
- Exactly.
I don't want to know about that yet.
- For me, usually I start
to get ready for bed
around eleven, and then I'll read in bed
and hang out with the wife,
and then kind of asleep by midnight,
and then awake at
seven-something, typically.
- Let me ask you this.
When do you feel like, out
of the 24 hours in a day,
when do you feel like your most productive
three or four hours are,
where you're like super
in the zone and hyper-focused?
Is it like, morning,
evening, what do you think?
- My default would be evening,
but after my morning
routine, and I love what you,
what did you say last time?
You had like a champion's
routine or something,
what did you call it?
- Prizefighter routine.
- Prizefighter routine, it was great.
I like that.
- In the morning, yeah.
After I go to my morning routine, I'm set.
So after I do all that stuff, then I'm set
for whatever I'm going to do next.
- That's my productive time, too.
It's right after my morning routine.
I have the most adrenaline,
the most energy.
I'm in the right state of
mind, so that's where I place
my highest-value activities,
is that first 60 minutes
after my morning routine, so I love it.
We're pretty similar in that sense.
So you want to?
- Okay, let's see what's...
Oh, go ahead.
- No, let's see what's next.
It's like the questions are coming in,
and we answered one, Peter,
so we got to be productive.
- I'll probably answer a
lot of them in the next
couple tips, but we can keep answering.
- A lot of them you have
already covered in the tips
as well, but I think you could go a little
deeper with some of them.
- Okay, cool.
People, well, okay, so
one person's asking,
how do you get in the
zone so you can be the
Michael Jordan of productivity?
What do you do to get in the zone?
- Okay, we're going to talk about that.
It's a good question.
But, I can dive in,
but let me wait for the
third tip, but it's a very good question,
and it's very important to
get yourself in the zone,
because when you're in the zone,
you're three times more productive, right?
So the second part of my five tips
dives into how this happens.
So number two is strategically
scheduling everything.
When you get everything out of your head,
and you put it on paper
and you delegate and sell
yourself on what you're doing
and what you shouldn't do,
that's when you start getting
more motivation to follow through.
So you have to have a seven-day review.
You have to think about,
in the last seven days,
how your week was, what you did well,
what you didn't do well.
When were you in the zone?
When were you distracted?
When were you at your best?
I always, every single week of every year
in the last three years,
I've planned my weeks.
It's a non-negotiable for me.
Because think about it, guys.
If you invest your past mistakes
into your future preparation,
you'll never have two bad weeks.
Here's a crazy fact that you,
you brought up Michael Jordan.
Michael Jordan averaged
around 30 points a game
his whole career, and
whenever he had a game
that was less than 20
points, that's not that good
for Michael Jordan, like 13, 14 points.
Whenever he had a game
less than 20 points,
his next game, he averaged over 40.
Now, let me tell you what
this means productivity-wise.
Michael Jordan never had two
bad games in his entire career.
Never, not once. Okay?
Why?
Because when he had a bad
game, what do you think he did?
Do you think he went out and drank beer?
No, he studied the game.
He studied the film.
He asked himself what he did different.
He watched the videos.
He was tough on himself.
He went back to the gym.
He worked out more.
He focused on his weaknesses
to turn them into strengths.
Most entrepreneurs have a bad week,
ah, whatever, it shouldn't happen again.
And it happens again and again.
That's why I don't understand how people
have bad years and then another bad year.
How is that humanly possible?
If you don't invest your
time into your mistakes
and make them better for the future.
So that's why I get so passionate,
because you got to review your weeks.
Now, here's what you put
in your schedule first.
Everything you can't change.
Whatever you can't change,
like business meetings,
calls with your team, maybe if
you're at a nine to five now,
you obviously can't change that, right?
Then, you put in what are you 100%
committed to making happen no matter what.
Whether, if you're in the
stage where you're not making
much money, it needs to be
profit-producing activities.
So what are your top three
profit-producing activities
that are proven to make you money?
Put that in your schedule first.
You would not believe,
Evan, how many entrepreneurs
I talk to at events and
at places, where they're
walking me through
everything they're doing
for the week, and they
have like a thousand things
on their agenda, but
none of them make money.
Then they're like, how do I make money?
Well, you should probably
do things that make money,
because everything you're
doing is not making money.
It's the busy work.
It's the easy stuff.
A lot of people don't
want to do the one or two
things that will actually help them.
So for me I also add in my schedule,
who am I going to reach out to?
Who am I going to connect with
that can cut my learning curve
in half, that can help me
get to my goals quicker?
So put in your schedule what you're
committed to making happen.
Put in your schedule your non-negotiables,
something you're committed
to, whether it's your health,
maybe it's working out four
days a week, maybe it's
alone time with you and
your wife or husband
or significant other, maybe
it's getting a massage
once a week to work on your peace of mind.
I don't know, but you got
to strategically put it
in your schedule, because
the trick to productivity
and to get in the zone
is deciding what you're
going to work on at some point
other than in the moment,
and then practicing the
high-value work over and over
'til it's habitual and automatic.
So, as far as number three,
and I'm going to answer
that question, "How do
you get in the zone?"
Here's exactly how I get in the zone,
and Evan already hit on it.
It's the prizefighter routine,
but it's understanding
about how to seize each day.
You only get each day.
Like, maximize your 24 hours,
and the rest of your life
will take care of itself
if you understand this.
So the first thing is you
have to get clear on what
morning routine is most effective for you.
You don't need to have 10
steps to a morning routine.
You don't need that.
You just want to focus on the outcome.
What's the purpose of a morning routine?
There's two things.
One, confidence, make
sure you're in a confident
and a courageous state of mind.
So whatever you have to
do to get in the right
state of mind, whether it's
working out, reading a book,
writing in your journal,
meditating, I mean there's
a thousand things you
could do in the morning,
and if you talk to 10 entrepreneurs,
all their routines are different.
Mine's different than
Evan's, but the reality is,
it gets us in the zone
when we start our day,
so they're both correct.
So the first thing is
get yourself in a better
state of mind, and the second
thing is having intention
and making sure you know
exactly what you're doing
that day and you put
your activities in order
highest value first, okay?
That's the purpose of a morning routine.
Next, I visualize and I
define my perfect day.
This sounded corny when I first
heard it, just being honest.
I was like, I'm not going
to visualize my perfect day.
That sounds horrible,
that's a waste of time.
But then I actually did it.
It's one thing to say
something's a waste of time,
it's another thing to actually do it.
I visualize, I think
about my ideal outcome,
how I'm going to feel
at the end of the day,
what my ideal day looks like, and, man,
it gets me so focused and
excited to complete that day.
And then I ask myself three
questions, and this is all,
guys, 30 to 45 minutes.
What am I most excited about for the day?
And if you don't have anything
that you're excited
about, create something.
What am I extremely grateful for?
It's impossible to be
frustrated when you're grateful,
by the way, so I always get grateful
so I'm not frustrated or discouraged.
And then what am I 100%
committed to make happen?
And once I do that, I finally
have clarity for my day,
and then it's the 60, 20,
60, where it's 60 minutes
no interruptions, no
distractions, straight focus
on my highest-value activity,
whether it's writing
in my book, creating
something for my mix tape
for one of my programs, whatever it is.
Straight focus for 60 minutes.
Then I take a 15, 20 minute break.
I either go walk around
the block, shoot some hoops
down the street, I watch a YouTube video.
You got to do something unrelated,
but the reality is here,
you ought to get out
of that state of mind,
and then when you're back
for the next 60 minute block,
now you want to make sure
you're fully focused again
in a new state of mind
and then sell yourself
on the activity that you're doing.
Sell yourself on whatever
you have planned.
If you're not sold on
the activity at hand,
that's when people procrastinate.
You will never procrastinate
if you fully sell yourself
on why you're doing what you're doing.
If you don't feel like
doing something, Evan,
maybe this video or whatever,
I almost guarantee it,
you think about why you're doing it.
You don't care how you feel in the moment
because you're doing it
for you, for your legacy,
for your family, to have freedom,
for income, peace of mind.
So if it's sold, you're
like, it doesn't matter
how I feel, I'm doing it.
But a lot of people don't sell themselves
on what they're doing.
And they're not really sold on it,
they're kind of doing it half-ass,
so that's when they
procrastinate and procrastinate.
So if you want to get in the zone,
you got to sell yourself
on everything you're doing
and you need to make sure you
get in the right state of mind
before you take something on.
And how you get in the zone is you work
straight for 20, 23 minutes.
That's how you get in the zone.
Most people, before they
even get to 20 minutes,
they're distracted, and it
takes 20 minutes to get back
in the zone, so they're
never actually in the zone,
because they're always distracted.
They're going from
distraction to distraction,
versus from in the zone to in the zone.
So hopefully that answered
some of the questions,
but this is something you
can tell I'm very passionate
about because I see
people wasting their lives
because they're not taking
the time to be disciplined.
Instead, they're working all the time.
So I could go on for a long time.
Any other questions?
- Dude, it's blowing up!
It's crazy!
Any other questions.
- I appreciate you guys, by the way.
- It's like it's off the page, man.
I have to pick which ones come up.
Uh, okay. This is interesting.
Esther.
Esther is saying, how do
you, this is about execution.
How do you lose the
fear/insecurity so that you
can go out and execute?
- Yeah. Couple things.
One, you have to be around,
and I've gone through this.
You have to be around, the
reason people don't execute
sometimes, Evan, is they
don't have certainty
that it's going to work.
That's why a lot of people
love the nine to five,
because there's certainty.
I'm going to get paid.
It's certain, right?
In entrepreneurship, there's no certainty.
So you have to increase your
certainty by a couple things.
When your certainty's increased,
like if I told you, Evan,
when you started, hey, when
you do this YouTube thing,
you will get two thousand
subscribers a day.
You're going to have a million subscribers
in exactly this time.
You're going to have this, this, this.
This is the money coming in.
You'd be like, oh, my God, that's easier.
But when you first started,
you didn't have that certainty.
You had to create the certainty
by getting the results.
So here's a couple things
that you can do to increase
your certainty, which then increases
your chances of execution.
One, do your due diligence, okay?
Do the research on what industry you're in
or what you're working
on to make sure you have
the best information to follow.
Two, get around other
people that are executors.
A lot of people that aren't executing,
every single person, and this is done
with a lot of study and me just dealing
with a lot of entrepreneurs in person.
A lot of people that aren't executing,
the five people they're around the most,
they don't execute either.
So if you're around other executors,
other people taking big action,
other people thinking bigger,
it's a lot easier for
you to execute, right?
And then three, like I just said.
You might have already got the answer.
Sell yourself before you
start taking that action.
So if it's like, okay, you want to...
For me, I'll tell ya.
My book, Six Months to Six
Figures, I'm so blessed
it's sold close to 200,000 copies.
It's gone crazy, right?
I didn't expect that.
When I was writing the book, it was hell.
A, you don't get paid for
writing a book until way later.
B, it's hard.
C, I'm like type A, I'm
freaking out, I'm jumping.
I did like 30 pushups before this
interview to get fired up.
But the reality is, I had to
sell myself a thousand times.
That's the only reason I
got it done and executed.
I said, you know, I just got
to visualize how it's going to
feel to get this book
done, to get this book
in someone's hands, and
I just kept thinking
about people saying, your
book changed my life.
Because of your book, I did not give up,
I didn't commit suicide, all these things.
That drove me, and I
couldn't stop the book
when I thought about that.
But most people think
about what they have to do
versus what they want.
So don't think about all you have to do.
Think about what you want
and your ideal outcome,
and it's just little bits and pieces.
Take a little more action
than the day before.
the next day than today.
Take a little more action
in two days than tomorrow.
And if you can do that, mixed
with doing your due diligence,
getting around higher-level
people, and making
the tougher decisions in
the moments, it's going to
give you the confidence to be
able to take bigger action.
But sometimes people
that don't take action,
they're just too, there's
too much noise in their head.
So try and simplify on
what you're doing and why,
and hopefully that helps,
'cause that's helped me.
Good question.
Really good question.
- I love it.
Marcus is asking, do you guys have
an accountability person?
How do you keep yourselves accountable?
- Yeah, so starting out, I did.
But I think when you
reach a certain level,
you don't really need one
because your habits take over.
People think inspiration
is what they need.
Inspiration is very
short-lived and short term,
and eventually, like when
you go to a seminar, Evan.
Not you, in general, but
when people go to seminars,
they pay five grand to go to the seminar.
After the seminar, and
they're fired up and excited.
They're motivated.
Two weeks later, they're
back to their old habits,
and they wasted that money.
So that's why you have
to put habits in place
versus just inspiration.
So I definitely recommend
having an accountability
partner, but it has to be
someone that challenges you,
that makes you think bigger,
that has the results you want,
that won't let you off the hook.
'Cause there's two types
of people, those who
make you think bigger, and
those who let you off the hook.
And most people are hanging
out with people who let
them off the hook to make them
feel better in the moment,
but you want to start doing
things now that your future self
will thank you for, right?
So I'd strongly agree.
I don't have one.
So here's the difference.
I have a lot of friends right now
that are doing amazing things.
Like my boy Gerard Adams,
some of you guys may know.
He just sold Elite Daily for 50 million.
He's a little older than me.
So I'm around a lot of people
that are doing big things.
That's enough accountability for me,
is just being around game changers, right?
So either be around high-level people,
or find someone in an accountability group
that challenges you, that
makes you think bigger,
that you know will hold
you to high standards.
Good question.
- Yeah, I mean, I agree.
I think I've never.
Have I never?
I have a mastermind group.
I don't use it for
accountability, mostly because
my own standards are higher
than anybody's on me.
And that's the thing, right?
You get to the point, I
think that's the bigger work,
is having such high standards for yourself
that I'm not going to do it because Joey
is going to tell me to do it.
I'm going to do it because...
- That's the next level.
I'm going to be pissed at
myself if I don't do it.
My expectations for myself are way higher
than what Joey thinks I'm going to do,
and I think that's the bigger work.
I think yeah, at the
beginning, maybe having people
to push each other and to
Peter's point about being
around people who are doing great things,
that could rub off on you, as well.
Or watching videos, like
why I make my channel,
have a little famous entrepreneurs.
I watched Elon Musk hitting it hard,
I feel, I got to do a little more,
I got to push a little harder,
but, yeah, I think that's
really the bigger game, guys,
if you could have your
standards be higher.
- And exactly what I meant by that!
When you level up, you
don't need other people
to tell you to go to work, to take action.
You don't need permission.
It's all on you, right?
But for you, Evan, how many people,
obviously you haven't counted.
How many people have said in the comments,
you changed my life?
- Oh, every day.
It's every day.
- So that keeps you going.
When you have a vision
bigger than yourself,
when you're impacting the world, I mean,
look at the people behind you.
They all impacted the world.
They were not on themselves.
It's called being on
purpose and off yourself.
For me, I don't care how I feel anymore.
I don't care if it's five
o'clock and I'm tired,
I'm not doing it for me.
I'm doing it for all the people
that I inspire and impact.
That's why I do what I
do, so at a certain level,
I don't need accountability
because it's not about me.
It's about those I inspire
'cause I want to make a mark
in this generation and impact
people and shift our culture.
And like you're doing as
well, impacting hundreds
of thousands of people, you
don't need accountability.
So, yes, you want
something at the beginning,
but you want to be so
driven and so focused
and have such high standards,
you really don't need that.
Good point.
- Peter, Peter.
We're already in the tens
of millions of people, bro.
Tens of millions of people.
- Tens of millions, my bad.
I forgot how much of a savage you are.
- And so this is an interesting
one now, about mindset.
Omar is asking, how do you
stay optimistic all the time?
- That's just my DNA.
I mean, I've tried both.
I've tried being a
pessimist and an optimist,
and optimism just works way better.
It takes the same energy
to be negative or positive,
so I'm just positive.
I just expect, so here's the key.
These questions are bringing
out some excitement in me.
I haven't got asked some
of these in a long time.
Here's the key.
When you're expecting, I expect the best,
but I don't get addicted to the result.
Because if you get addicted
to the result you want,
it's never going to happen
the way you want it.
So I am just focused on
doing everything I can,
focusing on the process and the journey.
I focus on doing what I'm supposed to do
and what I say I'm going to do every day.
I focus on the process,
and the results take care of themselves.
So I'm expecting the best.
If the best doesn't come, I
adapt and adjust and keep going.
So why I'm optimistic versus pessimistic
is because every single successful person
I'm around every day is optimistic.
Every person that's broke and
frustrated and talkin' shit
online or being a negative hater,
like, it's going to be funny.
We should look below after this,
see if there's any little haters.
I don't think Peter's telling the truth.
I don't think Evan's the real deal.
It'd be funny to see if there's any haters
hating from their mom's basement.
But the reality is, I've
actually never met someone
that's not successful that is negative.
So everyone that's successful
that I meet is optimistic,
so I've just kind of copied
and been around those people,
and I've seen it work.
And I've seen most people that
are negative and pessimistic
not have the results.
So I just chose to be positive.
It's just a choice that I
made, and that's really it.
It's just a choice,
based on what I've seen.
- Yeah, I think doing
the work that you love,
like to enjoy the process, not
be addicted to the outcome,
you got to actually
enjoy the process, right?
Like doing the work that you love.
If you're doing work that you love,
and not every day is
amazing as an entrepreneur.
You're going to have a lot
of down days, you know,
life's going to hit you in the
face really hard a lot of times,
but net-net, you like doing
the work that you're doing.
You're not doing it just
trying to make money
or get somebody's approval.
You're doing it 'cause
you enjoy doing the work.
I've done four
thousand-something YouTube videos
because I love making them.
I like it.
I love making the videos.
I love doing these interviews.
You know, I love doing it
whether it's having Peter
on and he's crushing it,
or it's on my other channel
where it's a brand new person
who's just getting started.
I like the process, and I
think if you enjoy the work
that you're doing,
you're going to naturally
be more optimistic.
- Hundred percent.
Quick recovery, short celebrations, guys.
When something doesn't happen
your way, recover quick.
If something happens amazing,
get excited for a second,
and keep pushing forward.
Don't get too excited about the positives,
and don't get too down
about the negatives.
Keep an even keel when you're going
through entrepreneurship.
- Let me ask you this,
because I don't celebrate.
It's like five seconds
and then we're moving on.
How much do you celebrate?
- Yeah, same thing.
It's the trait of an achiever.
I'm not doing it for celebrations,
I'm doing it for the long-term game.
So I'm the same.
To be honest, my wife
and some of my friends,
I'm pretty tough on myself.
Actually, a lot.
My standards are so high,
they have to tell me,
Peter, chill out.
Like, you just did a great job.
You just did this speech that was
in front of three thousand people.
It's amazing.
Yeah, I know, but I got to
do this and this and this.
You just did this course,
eleven thousand people
checked it out, so I don't celebrate a lot
because I'm focused on what's next.
So I think I do need to take a step back,
take a deep breath, and
be proud a little bit.
But, yeah, I think that's
an achiever thing, man,
'cause I'm the same way as you.
Did anyone tell you you
got to appreciate where
you've came from and enjoy it? Or?
- Well, so I have a ton of gratitude
for where I'm at, right?
Like, if it all went
away, I'm so appreciative
for what I have, but I
don't celebrate enough,
and it's something that's
on my mind, not so much
for myself, but for the team.
So I hit half a million
subscribers, my wife's like,
you got to go celebrate,
and I'm like what...
- Wives are always so positive.
- Yeah, I went, like I
took 20 minutes and walked
to the local donut shop and bought a donut
and came back and I ate
it, and was like, okay.
- That is not really your celebration.
- That was, man.
It's like, that's not enough.
I want to work!
I was like, 20 minutes,
that's wasted time.
But I did it 'cause my wife suggested it,
and I'm hoping that,
I'll try something once.
I'll try it.
And maybe I need to do
something bigger, I don't know.
It just felt like a waste
of time, and so, for me,
I don't need to celebrate, but I feel like
it actually hurts the team.
I feel like the team likes a celebration
and that I would be a better leader
if I celebrated more, or
let them celebrate more,
so we can hit the next thing.
I don't know, I feel like
it's a little piece missing.
I don't need it personally, but
for the team it's important.
- Yeah, I agree.
I think making your team feel
exceptional and making sure
that you let them know,
hey, guys, I'm focused
on the long-term vision
for us, but I really need
your help to make sure we
continue hitting these goals.
I want to go through, like
every week maybe going through
the goals they hit or the goals
that you guys are achieving
and making them feel amazing.
I think that's huge.
But, yeah, I've done that.
I've ran a pretty big sales
team, and I think a lot
of the legendary entrepreneurs,
if you stop and celebrate,
and you rest on your
morals, I think it's harder
to create the next thing
or build more success.
Because when Steve Jobs made an iPhone,
he wasn't like, oh, my God, this is it.
I have the iPhone.
What's next? What's next?
Let's continue changing lives.
Let's continue impacting the world.
So I commend you, because
I know you're an achiever,
and I can relate, but yeah,
my celebrations, too, Evan,
I travel three weeks out of the month.
I travel quite a bit across the world,
so that's kind of my, I work
sometimes while I travel,
which is why I became an entrepreneur,
but that's kind of my
celebration, is traveling
and seeing new cultures and
experiences and stuff like that.
But I love workin', man.
I'm addicted to the grind.
- I turn down most speaking things
because if it's a week
away, that's so much
opportunity cost lost of
what I'm going to do here.
I did a thing in Madrid last
year where I was helping
librarians and it was like
all the heads of the libraries
in the world came together to this event,
and they wanted to know
how to stay relevant.
So I'm speaking to them
about how to stay relevant.
- Wow, that's kind of cool.
- So that's actually a cool
cause, I'm willing to go,
but when I'm in Madrid, I'm not touring.
It's like, I don't want to do sightseeing.
I want to deliver mad
value to these librarians
and crush it, and then
make videos for my channel
and catch up on work and
maybe meet some local fans,
but I'm not out sightseeing
and trying restaurants
and I don't know.
- But you got to realize
that's why you're living
your life on your terms,
and that's why people
respect and look up to
you and why you have
five hundred thousand subscribers.
Most people are the opposite.
They want to speak real quick,
then they want to go and enjoy everything.
And most people are trying to
enjoy all these experiences,
before they really deserve
it or put the grind in.
So, you already know that,
but that's why you're
doing what you're doing
and why you're crushing it.
You know what I mean?
'Cause you're addicted to giving value.
Most people are addicted
to instant pleasure
versus giving value, so
people need to switch
their priorities and get in check.
- I like it.
- I love our conversations.
We could talk for hours, man.
You want to try and all-day marathon?
(laughs)
- All day marathon, dude.
That'd be massive productivity
for everybody here.
- Not us, but everyone else.
- Man, there's tons of questions.
Let me see what's one
that we haven't gone over?
Okay, so Joshua's writing,
I struggle to wake up
every day, and what advice do we have?
His work's being affected,
he feels like he's lazy.
Somebody who, like,
they watch this, right?
Everything's on fire, I love Peter.
Man, dude blew my mind.
I'm going to go crazy tonight,
and they're insanely productive,
and then tomorrow morning, I
don't want to get out of bed.
- Yep. I got a thought.
It's funny, every single
question I'm getting,
I've actually personally
been through that.
Been in ruts, been in struggles.
So a couple thoughts.
One, it's okay.
Be okay with that, but then
realize that you're one decision
away from changing it, and
whatever you're doing now
is 10 times worse in the future.
If someone is lazy now, they're 10 times
lazier in the future.
If someone cuts corners
now, they're 10 times worse.
If someone lies or exaggerates now,
(cuts out)
in the future.
That's why you got to be
super aware of your habits
and subconscious, who you're becoming.
First thought.
Most people go to bed tired.
If you go to bed tired,
you will wake up tired
100% of the time.
Flip that.
For me, I go to bed fired up and excited.
That's hard to believe, right Evan?
I go to bed fired up and excited.
So when I go to bed, I'm very grateful.
I say thank you whatever
higher power you believe in
for this six hours of sleep I'm getting.
When I wake up, I'm going
to be energized, juiced,
fired up and excited,
and I go to bed grateful
and I go to bed happy, right?
Now, it's a mind game you play.
In the morning when I
wake up, I still aren't
always excited, but I have a game.
Most people sleep in.
I'm not most people.
Most people make excuses.
You have this one-on-one
conversation with your head,
and then, you go from zero to 10.
So when you first wake up, you're a zero.
You have to do little things
that get you from a one
to a three to a five, and this has worked
for me 100% of the time.
So, first my alarm is
out away from my bed,
so when I'm dead tired,
my alarm is so annoying,
it's so loud, I have to get
up to actually turn it off.
So now I'm a zero, now
I'm like a two, right?
And then I go brush my teeth
or I drink a ton of water.
Now I'm from a two to
a three or four, right?
And then, for me, I'll do push ups.
I'll listen to my favorite song.
It's a habit now, so I
don't need to do this,
but when I was struggling,
I would do something
that got me from a three to a five.
So do something in the
morning right when you wake up
that gets you a little bit
more awake, and then do
something else, maybe it's do 10 pushups.
And then, look at some
statements or some quotes
that fire you up, and
then drink a ton of water,
brush your teeth, maybe walk downstairs
and start working out or go to the gym.
And then you're going
to be a seven or eight,
and then you're not going back to bed.
So I would sell yourself on why
you do want to get up early.
I would tell yourself the
night before that you're
going to be fired up, and
then I would also, right when
you wake up, have some
rituals in place that get you
from a zero to a two to a five to a seven.
And do that for seven to
14 days, then your habits
will take over your
mind and you'll be good.
So that's my thoughts, and
it's worked for me many times.
- Yeah, I've never had
a problem sleeping in.
I never press the snooze button.
- Awesome. Never.
- I think it's not even discipline.
If you wake, if you're doing
work that you want to do,
that you're excited to get
up and do, you want to...
Like for me, at night, I
have to shut my brain off
'cause I'm so, like here
are 10 of the things
I want to do tomorrow,
and then I don't sleep.
And then I got to get up
and start working on them,
and then it's like four in
the morning, and I got to
haul my butt to bed because
I'm not going to get
a lot of sleep tonight.
- Yeah, subconsciously, you're
excited about it though.
You have all these
things, like innovations,
you're planning on how to
add value, so even if you
can't sleep, you're fired up to get up.
All lot of times when I have
the most excitement and ideas,
I'm the same way, I
get up at four or five,
and I can't go back to bed.
I can't, because I'm fired up,
so that's funny you said that.
So you don't have an
issue ever getting up?
- I'm okay getting up, but I don't
wake up in peak state, either.
I'll get up, but I may start
at a five instead of being
at a 10, but I'm not at a one.
I'm not lying in bed and
like snooze, snooze, snooze.
I think that if you don't
look forward to what
you're doing, like on a
Saturday, I'm not sleeping in
and snooze buttoning, or Sunday.
It's just I want to enjoy life
and do stuff, and it's true.
If you've been sleep deprived
or you're not looking
forward to your day, then the
tendency is to be super lazy.
But in terms of getting
from a five to a six, seven,
eight, nine, ten, I
find music first thing,
like I'll wake up, I'll
go to the bathroom,
and then I'll put on a song.
And whatever the song is that gets you...
- Sparks your energy.
- Grinding, moving,
shaking, like my playlist
you may not enjoy.
It doesn't matter.
Whatever the song that works for you,
- Give me some artists.
- Changes your state.
AC/DC, Rolling Stones.
- Uh, none of those guys, man.
I just named a lot of people.
None of them?
(laughs)
- I don't think any of
them are on the list.
- [Peter] Pearl Jam?
- More like, I like some gamer music,
they've got some good beats
to it, or some remixes.
- You like Kygo?
- I don't know Kygo.
- It's like college music
but it's pretty good.
- Dude, like honestly, though, I know
a lot about a little bit.
- That's good.
You want to talk entrepreneurship,
you want to talk baseball,
maybe some League of
Legends, some salsa dancing,
we can go deep.
You want to talk pop culture
and music, and movies.
- Yeah, that's a good thing though.
You've focused on your strengths.
- No idea, no idea.
- That's a wise move,
my man, that's funny.
- Anyway, so like starting
with music, starting the day
with some music that gets
you excited, and then into,
I think if you're
consistent with the routine
and every day this is
how you do your thing,
then you just fall into it,
instead of to what Peter
said way back, you're not
just starting the day like,
what do I do today?
- Yep.
- Then you're super lazy,
where if you have your plan,
this is happening, you've written it down,
you're scheduled to it, then you're
much more likely to follow through.
- And think about how short life is.
You want to make sure if you
fast forward 10, 20 years,
you've maximized life out.
I want to look in the mirror,
Evan, when I'm 70, 80,
look in the mirror and
say I did it my way,
I maximized life, I have zero regrets.
If you can pinpoint what
you do today to your future
self thanking you for it,
that's a skill that a lot
of people cannot conceptualize
because they're so
addicted to instant pleasure.
I've been addicted to doing things now,
doing things today,
that January 1st, 2018,
I'm super proud of.
And if you could think like
that, that's the first step.
- I think, too, having a
keystone habit, like whatever
that first thing is, if
you do it, you're more
likely to do everything
else, and if you miss it.
- Yeah, yeah. Momentum.
- If you miss your, if you
have five goals and you want to
eat healthy, you want to
work out, blah, blah, blah.
If you eat a chocolate
bar, then you're likely
to give up on the rest of these.
You know what, I'm not going
to work out, and I'm going to
junk up the rest of the day.
You miss all your other goals.
So make that first thing
in your routine easy.
And then you stick to that
and you're much more likely
to stick to the other things.
So whether that's make your
bed, or brush your teeth,
or put on a song, whatever
it is, that first thing
is super easy, and then
the harder ones are later,
but you've built up
momentum to go through.
- 100%. I fully agree.
I love it man.
I mean, how much time do we have?
I could finish the last tip
and then we can do maybe
one or two more questions,
or we could just do questions
and I can finish with some final thoughts.
Whatever you feel, you're the man.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well initially I had us in
a half an hour where we're
almost at the hour mark.
- Oh, shoot.
- I know we got, we both
got other things to do,
but let me circle back.
I stopped paying attention
to the questions 'cause
it's just, it's flying through.
I want to circle back to
talk again about your,
you got your book, Six
Months to Six Figures.
You've got a master class
coming up that's launching
in about a month in February.
Talk to us about that
journey, making the book,
making this master
class, what's happening,
what everything's about.
- Yeah, so when I was
broke and frustrated,
I didn't know how to get out
of it, and finally there was
specific things I did when
I look back, on how I went
from broke to six
figures in actually five,
five-and-a-half months,
and people kept asking
about how I did it, so I
was helping a lot of people,
and I saw it work for them.
And all my journey up,
Evan, I read a lot of books,
and there was few that were
tactical that really gave
the actual scripts that were
done for you that really
helped me get to that next level.
So there wasn't any
books out there for young
entrepreneurs, so I wanted to create one.
So I put the framework in
the book, the six steps
to six figures, on exactly,
and we've had hundreds,
if not thousands of people,
say they've actually
used it and made six figures.
So this is not like I hope it works.
So the book is just a tactical
way, it's proven strategies
on what I used to go
from zero to six figures
and from six to seven.
So that's what the book is,
and I've got some amazing feedback.
It's been all over the world,
and I'm super proud of it,
but I also give a lot of my
scripts, like how I reached out
to high level achievers,
like the Vaynerchuks
and the Arianna Huffingtons and those kind
of people, the Mark Cubans.
I give my exact script on
what I did, I give a couple
other things that I personally,
I pretty much put everything in that book.
So we got so much feedback.
We have so many people reaching out.
Hey, I want more, I want more.
So we decided, we spent a year and a half,
me and a business partner,
creating a master class
on deep diving on each step.
If you don't have an idea
and you want an idea.
Anyone that's hungry, we give
them the exact strategies
and steps on how to get
to their first six figures
in entrepreneurship, and if you're at six,
it's pretty much how to
create the best six months
you've ever had, with
accountability, with strategies,
with tactics, and we
have a community around
where there's a lot of
people in there helping
and stuff like that.
So that's really what it is.
It's the most tactical,
comprehensive, and, I feel,
relevant training out for
entrepreneurs where they get
step by step system and a
proven roadmap on how to
not only create a product, how to sell it,
how to go from frustrated to crushing it,
and that's what it is, man.
It's just a roadmap for
entrepreneurs that want
to go to the next level this year.
So, yeah, we don't launch it much.
It's coming out, I think,
the end of February.
I'm excited about it.
- And if people want to either
find out about the course
or find out about you, you
do YouTube videos as well,
everything you're up
to, what's the process?
- Yeah, by the way, if you
guys say you're from Evan's
channel, I'd love to connect.
We get a lot of people
reaching out, but I've seen the
comments, you guys are
very hungry and dedicated,
so much respect to you.
We actually, I pride myself,
Evan, in giving better
free content than most pay thousands for.
I know your content's
better than a lot of people
that actually charge money for
what they're saying, right?
So at 6M6F.com, I created
a blueprint that mixes
this productivity stuff with
the Six Months Six Figures
framework, so I give you all
that value in a blueprint.
I think it's like a 10 or
12 page blueprint you get
for free, and that's at 6M6F.com.
And if they want to
connect on social media,
I have Instagram.
My Snapchat is Ambition
23, pretty active on there,
and then my Instagram's Peter
J. Voogd, and then if they
want to learn more about, we kind of have
an exclusive academy as well.
It's gamechangersmovement.com.
That's an invite only.
That's pretty exclusive,
but they can check that out
at gamechangersmovement.com.
But, yeah, man, I love to give value.
I love to help entrepreneurs
that are hungry,
that need guidance, because
I've been there as well.
Yeah, let's connect.
Add me on all social medias.
Let's talk some business.
I love it.
- All right, now this is it, Peter.
The final message of the day
that Pete is going to give us
to sum everything up
and leave us on a high.
What ya got, Peter?
- So the number one thing
that holds most people back,
I don't know what I'm going
to say as I'm saying this,
it always just comes
from the heart or gut.
The number one thing I've
seen hold people back
is they never tell themselves now matters.
They're always living on some day I'll.
Some day I'll be successful.
Some day I'll invest in myself.
Some day I'll quit my
job and start a business,
and some day never comes.
So I challenge each and every one of you,
right after this video,
what are you going to do now
to improve your chances of success?
You got to figure out
exactly what you want
and figure out what
you're willing to give up
to get what you want, and
if you can tell yourself
now matters, and you
stop comparing yourself
to everybody else, and
you only compare yourself
to who you were yesterday,
that's where you're
going to change the game.
And that's when you're
going to create a legacy
that outlasts you, so I'm here to help.
Evan's here to help.
Thanks so much for your
time, but that's it, man.
Like I said earlier, you
want to look yourself
in the mirror when you're
70 or 80, because 95%
of people, when they're 70
or 80, have massive regrets.
I'd rather have you guys
have massive excitement
and massive results than regret.
So look yourself in the
mirror when you're older,
and tell yourself I have no regrets.
I did it my way.
I maximized life, but it
starts with right now.
That's it.
- I love it. Peter Voogd,
ladies and gentleman.
Brings the fire every time.
Peter, man, thank you so
much for spending the time,
spreading some love.
Thank you guys for watching.
Sorry I didn't get to all the questions.
You know, you see the chat.
You guys are going crazy there.
- I'll try and get in
there and answer them, too.
I mean, I can't answer all, but I'll try
and get up in there and answer them, too.
- There' like a hundred questions
plus, that were not asked.
Be careful what you commit to there.
- Oh, that's funny.
- Thank you guys for watching.
I believe in you.
Continue to believe in yourself,
and we'll see you soon.
- See you guys.
Thanks, Evan.